just tell them we'll send it to them you
can sign this next week check it out I
know you don't want to give these away
the only the only way I get this one
away if Donald trades with me I do want
Cooper cups too oh man you're dangerous
I'm trying bro you know I try to keep up
with you bro doing you doing a great job
you know how you know how I feel about
you guys bro bro my mailbox been empty
for two years now I know I know I know I
know I know do it right now I'm I'm tell
my guy right now all right all right I'm
not going to get with you on the field
but I promise you I trust you I trust
you you know how you know can find you
too you know I can find you hey I don't
want to talk about this again I'mma find
you
bro come on you the only one I got in
the collection man you look good boy I'm
trying I'm trying to move all over